thank
foreign
good morning everyone and welcome to
jay's meeting
council has assembled and choose that
circumstances how we collectively mourn
our late queen
before we begin the meeting i think it's
only right and proper for the council to
observe the limited silence
i will ask you to stand for this and
silence will be followed by a short
prayer
and this prayer will be led by ang
panesti the licensed reader of all
saints church here
[Music]
our prayers are to commemorate our late
queen elizabeth ii
and then for our new king king charles
iii
eternal god our heavenly father
we bless your holy name for all you have
given us in and through the life of your
servant elizabeth ii
we give you thanks for her love of
family
and her gift of friendship
for her devotion to this nation and the
nations of the commonwealth
for her grace dignity and courtesy
and for her generosity and love life
for the courage she showed in testing
times
the depth of her christian faith
and the witness she wore to it in word
and deed
today we remember her family
our royal family as they mourned the
mother grandmother
great-grandmother
reassure them of your continuing love
may they find some privacy to grieve for
her
solace as the public demonstrates their
sadness and respect
and give them the peace that you alone
can give
amen
we pray for our king
king charles iii
as he assumes his many responsibilities
may he find support and strength for the
way ahead
direct his steps and guide his paths in
the days and years to come
granting wisdom strength and courage
that he may rule wisely and well
with the support of government and
people
guide us also
that we may play our part
in the building of a fifth nation
ready to play its part
in the fellowship of the world
we pray these prayers in the name of
your son our savior jesus christ
amen
[Music]
it would not be appropriate for this to
proceed with the published degenerations
following consultations with greek
leaders and in line with what has
happened in parliament i intend to use a
motion to defer all of the business from
after the apologies of absence
i will then propose that there should be
one item for the meeting the death of
the majestic agreement i will allow all
members present to speak on this
medication
at the conclusion of the item council
will be asked to vote to agree emotion
setting out our great sadness at the
death of her
[Music]
also just to confirm that the agency
there today will be taking an
extraordinary meeting which you will be
pulled off shortly
finally a reminder that the meeting is
being live streamed for the council's
youtube channel
before we begin i would like the
monitoring officer which is always done
we must
[Music]
there are quite a few
councilman
council peter elliot council mark foster
councillor lee hartson councillor micro
councillor tony lacy councillor heather
lydia
councillor martin plucker
councillor kevin tate
council morning council jones and
council rehabs
[Music]
um
and uh councillor hopkins
[Music]
[Music]
thank you i will now propose a motion
for further business on the published
agenda 23rd until the extraordinary
meeting and that the council today
considers only one item the subject of
her majesty queen elizabeth ii
do we have a second yeah
the death of the majesty through
elizabeth ii
[Music]
i will allow everyone to speak on this
but i propose to do it in a structured
way
i will call on the leader of the council
to speak then we will move the motion
then counts for barca to speak and
second promotion i will then ask the
leader of the liberal democrat group and
the leader of the independent group to
speak
followed by the deputy leader council
charlotte pupil
i will then follow other members to
speak in the order in which they raise
their hands and i recognise them
finally after everyone has spoken i need
to intend to say a few words to express
my own sorrow and then to call on
members to support the motion of
condolences
[Music]
thank you chair
i hope i speak for more than just myself
when i say there is something somewhat
surreal about this moment
somehow
i never really thought we'd be in this
situation
clearly we all understand the cycle of
life
and the stark reality
that her late majesty's reign would
eventually come to an end
but there remains something still that
is quite unbelievable about the whole
thing
it is perhaps testament to the longevity
of her reign
she's been a constant in all of our
lives
and in the public consciousness
for more than 70 years
she reigned for more than double my
lifetime
and lived for almost tripled
she she's represented continuity
constancy
dependability
consistency
loyalty
and steadfastness
but i think it goes so much deeper than
that
our admiration for her
and the highest esteem that so many of
us hold her late majesty in
is because of who she was as a person
and as a leader of our great nation and
commonwealth venerated around the world
when i think of that
i've i think of someone who personifies
all of the qualities
of the greatest of great leaders
humility
dignity
grace
a profound sense of duty and service
and a loyalty and devotion to her
country
but her great respect for all peoples
around the world and it's different
cultures
patience
thinks particularly of how she
persevered with 15 different prime
ministers perhaps a good amount of
patients with a prerequisite to the
wrong
a fantastic sense of humor
probably another prerequisite for the
role
an ability what's more a duty to
transcend politics
to connect with people
not on the issues that mattered to her
but on the issues that mattered to them
an ability to know what to say
when to say it
and equally
when to say nothing at all
and yet still
an incredibly high level of visibility
to her people
she said herself
to be seen is to be believed
and she lived by that she met millions
of people in her lifetime
an analysis suggests around one third of
the uk population either met or saw her
in person
perhaps most importantly of all
just like all of us she was human
she had to deal with tragedy and
relationship breakdown
and so many of the things
that we all sadly have to bear
as well as the rash of other human
emotions
but importantly
she never lets any of these things
stand in the way of fulfilling her duty
to her people
and that
is loyalty in its purest form
that i think is why her late majesty was
such an inspiration to so many around
the world
her amazing dedication to every single
one of her 70 years in public service
and the dignity and humility with which
she approached her role is truly
awe-inspiring
she will doubtless be remembered in the
hearts and memories of so many of her
loyal subjects
in so many ways she was the mother
of our proud modern nation
and without doubt
the greatest of britain's
cabinet and senior officers are already
considering several different lasting
ways in which we can commemorate her
late majesty
in accordance with national protocols
and the wishes of the palace and we will
communicate with members further on this
in due course
i'm sure i speak for all of us when i
say that our thoughts prayers and
heartfelt condolences
are very firmly with his majesty the
king
and all of the royal family at this
extremely difficult time
i say to them that no establishment
along with the nation
and the commonwealth
grieves with you
for this tremendous loss
and in these the most bittersweet of
days
we wish the new king well for a long and
glorious reign
and i'm sure we speak with one voice
in saying god save the king
i'm conscious chair that there will be
many others who wish to speak
so without further ado i'm very happy to
propose the following motion
on behalf of the residents and
communities of northeasternership
we express our deepest sorrow
of the passing of her late majesty queen
elizabeth ii
who served the nation in commonwealth
with such dedication
during her extraordinary reign
we extend to his majesty king charles
iii
and the wider royal family the heartfelt
sympathy and deepest condolences
of north establishing district council
and its residents thank you
thank you
councillor can now address the council
yeah thank you jeff
it's
it's very difficult to think of what to
say at times like this we are repeating
what what other people have said
uh it's been on television
or a week
so we're asking some advice from people
and somebody said well you have to do
some sort of anecdote involving the
queen
i thought that's going to be difficult
since i've never met it
well then i remembered and this is this
through the time i was coming back
so they stopped the bus and about 30 of
us they're off this bus i think the only
one person stopped don't bust so 30
miners that have been at fifth all
morning or all day got off this bus and
stood up banking it they played around
with that and we all waved to this car
we don't
do it
that their popularity was i mean
to be honest both want to get home but
we'll go off and wait and uh
but seriously though i couldn't uh
believe how i felt when a death were
announced basically
i was generally moved genuinely military
when her majesty's death was confirmed
and i don't know if it's just me but the
emotions i felt were very much like when
my mum died no longer and it that
surprised me
and i suppose that's what sums all
what a lot of people have been saying
about it
she's like a mother figure to many
people
and for me to compare anyone to my mum
is indeed a massive tribute and not
something i do like
many people have got respect and
admiration for the service that she's
given and the devotion to the duty
despite some difficult times
and she was an inspiration to many
so it is with much sadness that i on
behalf of the labour group
express our thoughts and condolences to
the royal family and offer our best
wishes to king charlotte
in his new role so i'm i'm more than
pleased
uh to move
the emotion and
a good speech
alex
thank you
thank you
thank you hello thank you chair it's
obviously
with sadness that we're of the death of
her majestic queers ii throughout her
reign which has been a beacon of
stability during an area of
unprecedented change
her dignity and strength of character
have served this country through many
highs and lows and to many she'll be
remembered fondly for reign as our
longest serving head of state
it's one of those moments like the
leader said where you just don't think
it's ever going to happen somehow we all
believe that she would
go on forever um which sadly is not the
case
and on behalf of the liverpool group in
particular the residents of tucson and
which we represent would like to offer
our deepest condolences to our family
make sure you rest in peace and we wish
along that's a successful reign to
control the third
thank you
1953 when the queen's coronation took
place she gave a declaration to the
nation i have in all sincerity to pledge
myself to your service
throughout my life and with all my heart
i shall strive to be worthy of your
trust
70 years later
she said to the
nation
there is no guidebook to follow it
really is a fair
i remain committed to serving you
to the best of my abilities
in 70 years the place still remained
and the service she delivered over that
time has been exemplary
and i would support the comments that's
already been said about what the queen
did i never actually met the queen
um
but i did meet prince charles
i thought my daughter
met prince charles
and i asked her for some comments
and she said along with my school
friends i met the now
king charles iii at crawford mills
i wasn't very old which i remember being
very nervous
before he arrived and scared it out
saying the wrong thing
i also remember that when he did come
over to shake my hand
i ended up not feeling nervous at all
because he was very kind and calming
and he seemed genuinely happy to be
there
i've also met principal the booking of
palace
and it was a garden party in age of the
princess trust
so along with rob stewart we had
sandwiches on the lawn at buckingham
palace
and the prince walked around shook
people's hands and he was generally
interested
in what we were doing the youngsters
were helping and how their future was
developing
and i'm sure he'll carry that forward
in his new role as king charles iii
so who knows what the future holds
whether you're a pro royal and
anti-royal or indifferent
this is a time of change that will
affect us all
and i'd just like to say god save the
king thank you
thank you um i hope the tributes already
made by the great leaders and like us
all i'm deeply saddened by her late
majesty's passing and i know my
condolences without landing emotion to
all members of the royal family as first
and foremost they've lost a close-up on
on the native family queen elizabeth ii
always reminded me strangely for my
great grandma and my late grandma who
herself was a big fan of the lake queen
commemorative cups and all
and there were many things to celebrate
and commemorate during her reign
but that reminder for me i think also
encapsulates two of the reasons for the
loss we're all feeling at the moment and
which i'd like to pay tribute today
i make the link because in many ways
queen elizabeth was like part of the
family several members have already said
and as part of every family in the
country and commonwealth ever presence
and steadfast and changing times she was
someone we always look to to help make
sense of and feel united in challenging
and sometimes lonely times such as the
pandemic but also in happier times too
such as his features our tradition every
christmas
no matter what was happening even if the
turkey was burning when the late queen
spoke we all stopped to listen
the other reason for the reminder of my
grandma is she inspired the spirits of
that generation and indeed i think of
all those sins
the late queen embodied the very slogan
of keep calm and carry on
i'm sure she faced very difficult days
during her 70 years on the throne but we
would never really know it and she just
got on with the job
she was always ready with the quiet
power she possessed from the soft
diplomacy which seemed to come out
effortless effortlessly to her when
representing her nations amongst other
world leaders i think we've seen the
power of that from the global reaction
to her passing but also to the
reassurance and ease she radiated when
meeting anyone
any of my residents who have had the
privilege of meeting there always say
this to me
and the example i always call in mind to
encapsulate this perfectly is one i
actually read a few years ago
of the support she gave an army surgeon
with ptsd you have an attack during the
lunch with her and you should just
calmly sat with and federal court views
with him to
[Music]
all of this demonstrates to me that
queen elizabeth recognized that politics
in all senses of the word and that is
essentially life
is always about people
and that's who she devoted her life to
serving
with that whilst i think you feel the
queen's lost so keenly now she has and
hopefully should continue to be an
inspiration to us
so with the chairs indulgence to quote
thank you for everything man okay thank
you i'm now going to open the floor so
please stay with me if i don't see your
hands
counseling
she loved the people
she loved our kingdom her other realms
and territories
she gave her life for all of us
i do remember seeing the lay queen in
matlock it was around 2012
and we all lined the streets to watch
her and her husband go pass
and it was incredible to be able to see
harmonic in the flesh it was
overwhelming it was amazing
the late queen said
grief is the price we pay for love
and
we are definitely paying that price for
the love that she gave us and which we
gave her
and we are all morning i'm definitely
morning i feel as though i've lost a
relative
i feel blessed to have lived in the
second elizabethan age
even if just for 27 years out of this 17
but now we have a new king
of whom i swear my allegiance and
absolute loyalty
i say our prayer and are on them with
christ
god save the kingdom
thank you
thank you
thank you
i always struggled to comprehend how one
could show such out of emotion in greece
someone never knew
but when the news broke on thursday
evening the tears fell
much has been said over the last few
days about their majesty not just within
the united kingdom but from across the
world
without repeating the same words but
surely a testament to her legacies and
character
none of us knew her intimately yet we
all feel that she is part of this we've
not known anything else her majesty has
been a constant throughout all the major
events we have all that through
and what's an incredible life her
majesty lived a long life that wished
for her and she never heard or strayed
from the commitment she made when the
crown was disposed of such a young age
the monarchy has changed even within my
own lifetime it has evolved as all
things must but it is an institution
which i feel proud we have
things will now change we have a king
for the first time in most of our
lifetimes the televised christmas speech
will be strange this year not seeing her
majesty's face or hearing her voice
but it will still be there and that is
the point
in a world where tradition history and
ceremony are often downgraded the
monarchy provides a constant bridge
between our past and our future
finding it all together in shared
experiences good all that
however we choose to remember green she
was our queen
and we all have our own impressions of
what the queen meant to us
aside from her sense of duty love of
country and state and position
from a personal perspective when i think
of their majesty i always think of her
love
and i think this aspect will resonate
with many residents within my world also
a passion for horses dogs country wars
country life in general it was her
beloved moral that she chose to spend
her final days not london and it was a
game keepers he looked after her and
started her on her final gym a touching
mark of respect for ensuring successful
service and duty are two words
inextricably linked with emergency and
whatever your feelings on the monastery
as an institution i think we can all
agree that this lady has served our
country and fulfilled their commitments
putting beyond the call of jesus
her majesty had the ability to bring our
nation together regardless of background
experience or political persuasion in
moments of struggle and even in that
you've brought our country together one
final time and shared through
so thank you man for your eternal
service you will surely do this and then
you rest in peace up to a long life of
jesus
on behalf of myself and the community of
following himself i send my condolences
to his majesty the king and the wider
family
let us not forget as my wife keeps
reminding me that in addition to being a
monik she was also a mother a
grandmother even a great grandmother and
that love is something we can all
emphasize
with
god
queen elizabeth ii became queen at the
age of 25.
during our queen's reign her majesty has
seen so many changes which has worked
quietly with the dignity which has been
second to none
our queen elizabeth was obviously
adulting mother and grandmother and
great grandmother i'm sure we all
recognise what the difficult job this
was to balance all of her duties while
spending time
with and supporting her family
our queen has reigned over us for so
long as i can remember
the only thing i can actually remember
from that day was having the child's
union jackal
actually
losing her death
brought back a shock around the world
always our country with a quiet dignity
our queen will suddenly be missed
i'll send my condolences to their
majesty's family and i wish i knew king
charles iii belonged and successfully
okay thank you
thank you
basically mine is just to show something
of my uh thoughts
and feelings about queen elizabeth ii
i always think about how i wear
why we were when we were growing up in
our household
mom and dad
we've got to take charge
and control
a house full of homeroom wickets
i've been there seeing it and now i'm
doing it because of my great granddad
and
yeah i can see how it's come across
both for the queen and for the rest of
the mothers and fathers across this
nation
i've got two or three things that spring
to mind with regards to
not only the queen but from those i've
mentioned before
in one respect she got the compassion
and thought
of mother teresa
she can be measured she can adjust
but also on the other hand
she got the fortitude and tenacity the
bonus here
because when it was necessary
she took charge
again
the strong qualities
are measured
and resonant
and may god bless her
thank you are there any other comments
a huge range of emotions
but mainly a suddenness belique of
gratitude
so i share
[Music]
a constant presence in the lives of so
many people across the world and for her
wonderful words of wisdom and guidance
through difficult times which gave us
all so much comfort and hope
i feel so humbled to have listened to
all the tributes paid over the weekend
have acts of kindness and steadfast
dedication to duty and service we owe a
great
detail of gratitude and debt and
her majesty for all that she was but
also the legacy that she leads
so may she rest in peace and don't say
thing
[Music]
[Music]
with deep sadness that removed the loss
of queensland
following a lifetime of devoted public
service
majesty
queensland has a role model for every
citizen in britain and indeed the
commonwealth and across the world
with an appeal that transcended
generations
she was a symbol of dedication
loyalty and a verbal repression of hard
work with a strong sense of duty to a
country
through times of strife and celebration
quinlan's best perceptions reign with
dignity and courage
a legacy will continue to inspire
generations
i'm a very personal note if i may as
someone who worked in france the
republic
the queen has always held a very special
status to us
and for many of us young people in
france
she was the only sovereign that we knew
we knew about for many years
and we looked at you with envy
and we wondered why couldn't we have a
queen obviously i now know why
and
she was a symbol of a great country
she represented strength
resilience and unity
at least though i think she will be
remembered by many across the world
i'm very proud to have been able to
serve the public for creating some very
small ways
under her reign
and i know that many of us in drone 4
many of my residents
will miss her
will feel a great servant
and we know we will miss our strengths
our authority
and guidance
and from drumfield our thoughts and
prayers
are with the royal family at these very
difficult times
and residents of canada joined us
yesterday for the proclamation
so god taking childhood
[Music]
[Music]
and
i think one of the
really good things
that will come out of this is the fact
that
it's not just
our generation generation
[Music]
um
of
that generation have responded
um it's probably the first time
[Music]
a friend of mine said to me
the other day that on the friday
she got a text from her daughter who was
at school and said that it was all about
the tick tock
um and indeed it was a tick tock and she
said that um
people weren't realizing that she'd gone
to scotland
that's her favorite place
and um that she probably wanted to
rest in peace
in banmory
[Music]
um
clearly my friend was right but
something that sheldon said reminded me
of uh
an occasion where i was
sitting next to um
uh
[Music]
working relationship
um
and then so this is a second hand
but debbie said he was sitting next to
her majesty at a full dinner
um now one day his food arrives on the
table
he always very gently runs his fingers
over a plate
to make a sort of mind a map of where
everything is
vegetables
i i've sat there quite a number of
and as usual i said david would you like
me to test up your meat in case he was
chicken
and he said yes please
and then he told me that
he'd been sitting next to her majesty
and i've done the same thing
and the queen said to him
mr blanket would you like me to cut your
meat
and uh david said that because it was
queen he couldn't possibly say yes
your
[Music]
and i think i think that kind of
demonstrates another aspect of
[Music]
[Music]
yes having spent five years at the
shepherd city battle school on labor
street right in the heart of shetty city
center
followed by 53
working years within the almost
immediate city center
[Music]
[Music]
by a teleport yes television
on the morning of the 6th of february
1952 the teen george
had died
and i ran home at lunchtime
who immediately switched the radio to
their own service which confirmed my
message
the following easter 1953
two weeks after queen mary died on the
24th
but
of
march
decided to take my mom
my elder brother and myself to ken for
three days holiday
uh over the years all of it
he's just received a brand new austrian
a7 peripheral
[Music]
dover for the first time my dad took us
to windham
on the way home really just to view
all of the floral tributes to queen mary
within windsor castle which were equally
many of what you are now seeing on our
teletubbies
even black and white televisions were
not a common sight until towards the
queen's coronation in june 1953
upon releasing my dad drove his car down
towards where the normal road crosses
over what is known as the long walk
which drops down from windsor castle
onwards for approximately a mile away it
then flattens out
without being
[Music]
[Music]
and as he jumped out together my mom
said
you can't park yet i think you've just
i think i've just seen a company
which turned out to be correct as there
was a tip in the long walk
by which time my dad had walked around
that car
[Music]
to allow my dad the time to get back in
the car start the engine and move to
that car console
as the car passed across the front
the tool should be in the other car with
the young queen management
driving
with princeville
intensive market
and one of them we didn't recognize
so really we just could not believe it
and guess what
my dad's being completely started being
at any point yet now that
my second
um
occasion was on the 24th of october 1954
when the new queen expressed a wish
and meet all of the 43 000 school
children of sheffield which took place
at the shepherd wesley's football
stadium with hillsborough
many of you and may have seen a glimpse
of the canyon on the north this last few
days
three thousand of the children were
wearing are the red white or blue
t-shirts
and formed the large capital letters
conveying a message to the royal couple
welcome to sheffield after which the
children regrouped into a rectangle and
then dropped it down onto their hands
and knees
forming the union jack knife and then on
the whistle
they all whittled their bottom which
made the flags of
the queen and you then climbed into an
open top land rover then a relatively
new vehicle made especially for the
platforming
community
another little antibiotic from the same
very schedule was her first visit to the
cutlass hall
after the cathedral in church street
obviously the master settlement
[Music]
and in those days all my walls and
[Music]
however as the ceiling was going to be
repainted
they thought it would be a good idea and
plan to not only love the two
magnificent chandeliers
uh not by the delboy and romney i mean
but so
[Music]
upon rewiring the day before the biomass
was due
the election
[Music]
which was
and nowadays it's just the original
stained wood flooring
all went off very well and even today
there's still a beautiful watercolor
painting campaigning from the queen at
that visit in 1954.
thank you are there any other comments
i'll just like to take time to read
counselor joe burton's
message he did contact me this morning
with his apologies that he would like
this message
she was a constant fixture throughout
the united kingdom and the commonwealth
which i believe gave support in their
lives their devotion to duty despite
difficulties was an inspiration to many
some counselors
i'll finish the semester with my message
which is very short and very screened
this afternoon many tributes have been
paid to our fate coins in the second
[Music]
my thoughts
image in the morning
that leaves really just one thing for me
to say
thank you your majesty for your lifetime
dedication and service
may you now rest in peace god save the
king
thank you
i think it's good that the council has
come together in this way at such a sad
time
many things have been said today and
many emotions have been expressed
i don't want to repeat them but rather
just to make the following points
first of all
what is i am to be the chair of this
council
i truly wish that i was not here today
having to preside over a meeting to
mourn the passing of our mother
who has been part of everyone's life for
so long
but i do it because it is my duty and in
my own small way because i am your
servant
let us all remember that as well as
being our queen
elizabeth was also a servant to a
soldier
who devoted her life to the people of
this country
if you did your duty we will always
remember
can we just have a few moments of quiet
reflection
[Music]
i would like a vote to be taken i'm
going to ask that we do this by roll
call
so the record will show how this
historic occasion will be acted as one
council
[Music]
thank you chair i'll read each name in
turn starting with the w's
councillors
[Music]
shipment four cancer right four cancer
rouse full cancer ridgeway
cancer renic
cancer pal
cancer pots four cancer fats
of hickory four council parking
four councilman lilly
paul councillor lewis
councillor kerry four councillor kenyon
or
councillor hall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from caretakers to directors and all the
support staff in the organisation of
nato the book creation league region
yesterday but also for the short service
held on friday it was a privilege to
work alongside such a great team of
people
it was proud to be part of this council
thank you
there is no further business
you